Hello, I'm Linda you and kind of nurse and author of the great economists.
Welcome to this video episode of the intelligence squared podcast.
I'm delighted to be joined by Reese Weideman contributing editor at
New York magazine to talk about his new book, billion dollar loser,
subtitled the Epic rise and spectacular fall of
Adam Newman. And we work.
So we work is a coworking office space company founded about a
decade or so ago and was the largest office tenant in New York city.
And second in London next to only the UK government valued at
$47 billion at its peak.
It was the second most valuable private startup in America.
It then had a failed IPO in 2019 that the New York times described as
quote an implosion, unlike any other in the history of startups.
So, Bruce,
let's talk about what happened to we work and that's co-founder and CEO,
Adam Newman. So you open the book with a quote about Adam Newman, um,
and you quote his high school teacher who said, quote,
either Adam will end up in jail or he'll become a millionaire.
So why did you open with that quote?
Well,
we thought it was fitting cause I think part of what's interesting about this
story and what was interesting about it to me as I reported on,
on the company was that all of the good things about we work are not all,
but a lot of the good things and the reason it was successful, um,
stemmed from Adam Newman, um, as did a lot of the reasons it fell apart.
And so it was interesting to find that that kind of this,
this personality that he had of someone who was, who was so ambitious, um,
and, and, you know, so charismatic and,
and always, you know, going at 110%, uh,
with their way back in, in high school.
And everyone could kind of re recognize that he was not going to be someone who,
you know, just kind of disappeared into the ether.
He was going to do something interesting, maybe a little crazy,
maybe successful, maybe not. Um, but whatever it was,
it was going to be interesting to watch what happened to Adam from there.
And you're right, that some employees that we work,
you spoke to compare Adam Newman to Steve jobs,
both emanated a quote reality distortion field
that convinced anyone within this radius that the impossible was not only
plausible, but exactly what they were going to do.
So in June
we work employees and mentioned that many of them use the opportunity of your
conversations as a free therapy session.
So what was your impressions of the employees as they were in this reality
distortion field health, and how did you conduct the research for this book?
Well, there was, there was.
Kind of a shift for people. I think, you know, when,
when a lot of employees got there in, in coming from,
in some cases straight out of college,
in other cases from kind of boring jobs elsewhere, they were really excited.
And, and to hear Adam get up on stage and tell them, you know,
we're not just renting out office space, we're changing the world.
We're making a difference in people's lives. Every single day was,
was really inspiring to people. And,
and I think some of them had never had a job before didn't know what was kind of
quote unquote normal at a company. And, and, and so, you know,
when they found themselves working 80 hours a week, 90 hours a week,
they could kind of justify it in their heads because of the way Adam talked
about, uh,
what they were doing by the end of things after the IPO had fell apart.
Um, as I started to talk to more and more people who had,
who had left the company either willingly or unwillingly, they,
they were sort of jaded. And,
and often they talked about their experience in as if,
um, we work with some kind of cult that they had kind of escaped from, uh, in,
in a certain way that that was exciting for a while.
But eventually you sort of realize, um, that, uh,
you you're working your whole life is wrapped up in this company.
All your friends are, are at this, at this, uh, at the company.
Um, and, and you're sort of uncertain why you did this,
especially given how things ended up.
Wow. So just to say a bit about your research for the book,
I'm thinking you write about in the book and that you've talked to hundreds of
employees.
Yeah. So I started reporting on the company back in the spring of 2019 back when
things were sort of still flying high, the company was worth $47 billion.
The IPO hadn't even been announced yet. Um, and at that point,
when I was just sort of writing a feature story for New York magazine,
we were just interested in the company because suddenly our office in Soho in
New York was surrounded by half a dozen Weaveworks seemingly sort of overnight.
So it was trying to kind of look at, um, what, uh,
just how this company had grown so quickly, so fast. And,
and as I started reporting then, um, again, back in,
uh, the spring of 2019, um, it became clear that,
that there were some unusual things about the company and that all of them, as,
as we talked about at the top, uh, stemmed from Adam, um, and,
and it was difficult to get people to talk about the company. And,
and this is kind of the struggle of reporting about any of these kinds of high
flying startups is, is that on the way up everyone on the inside is,
is kind of incentivized to go along with things, even, even if the,
the things that they're seeing, um, uh,
give them pause. Uh, and, and that could be for one reason or another one,
one reason is that we were kind of cracked down on, on people a lot who,
who speak out, um,
and the other was just that people thought they were going to get rich. Um,
if you were an executive at this company, or even a low level employee, um,
you were being told over and over again by by Adam and others,
that we're going to go public one day,
your stock's going to make all this work that you did worth it. So,
so it was hard early on to get people to talk, um,
once the IPO fell apart and that incentive kind of went away and people were
frankly kind of upset with Adam, um,
it was much easier to get people to speak about their experiences. And that, uh,
as, as you said, I ended up talking to a few hundred people, uh,
who worked at the company, um, both from the most junior ranks,
all the way to the most senior people, um, within WeWork, uh,
as well as kind of this,
the investors and the landlords and all the people who sort of circled around
the company and dealt with Adam over the years.
And retain a bit more about what Adam Newman was like when you
interviewed him for the book, you describe his office as having,
not just a private bathroom, but also a sauna.
Yeah. He had sort of a two room suite, uh, kind of back in the corner.
He had this kind of sauna and cold plunge tub, uh, that,
that had been installed. And there was a certain irony to the whole thing.
You know, the,
the business of WeWork was squeezing people into these famous glass cubes
that they, they had, uh, installed all over the world. Um,
it was squeezing people into smaller and smaller spaces. And,
and here was Adam in, in kind of a pretty large office by,
by any standard. You know, that being said, you,
you could sort of recognize in meeting him kind of some of the reasons that that
people bought into what he was selling,
whether that was investors or employees or,
or whatever audience he was addressing. He, he was just the kind of person who,
um, is, is charismatic, who,
who makes you kind of knows what you want to hear and,
and makes you believe in, in kind of what he's he's selling.
So that was one of his great skills. And I think, you know,
even in just sort of a brief interaction with him, you can see how,
how people were, were attracted to, to being around him.
And give us a sense of the New York real estate world,
where we work started. Um,
so you describe how Adam Newman and Jared Kushner president Trump's son-in-law,
who was also the real estate. Um,
so tell us how they resolve disputes. I think, uh,
shots and arm wrestling might've been involved.
Yeah, well, well, yeah,
New York real estate is real estate anywhere has no shortage of colorful
characters. And, and, um, you know, yeah, both,
both Adam and Jared Kushner were kind of young,
real estate guys in,
in the city coming out of the last financial crisis. Jared was,
was trying to push his family business more and more into Manhattan.
Adam was growing his business there.
They were about the same age and they connected. Um, and, and we worked at, uh,
did a few deals, um, with, uh, with Kirschner's, uh,
properties, both in Brooklyn and Philadelphia. And as you, as you mentioned,
you know, they, they came up with a colorful way to kind of resolve one dispute,
which was, um, uh, an arm wrestling match in, in Adam's office.
We were headquarters, uh, in lower Manhattan. Um, Jared lost, uh,
Adam bragged about how he had,
had done a lot of arm wrestling when he was in the Israeli Navy. Um,
Jared did object to the, the loss, um, and,
and demanded a rematch, but, but he lost that one as well.
So we work, uh, one, one out on that deal.
Well, um, okay. So in a nutshell, um,
how did we work, grow so fast.
A few things, uh, all of which STEM from money, um, is, is,
is sort of the easy answer. I mean,
if you go back and look at the early days of the company,
they were not the first people to invent the idea of flexible office
space or coworking, or the various things that they did.
There were other operators already. What, what Adam had was on the one hand, um,
ambition, you know, a lot of people who run these companies are,
are happy to have a few spaces in one city here or there. Um, and,
and content with that, and content was slow growth,
Adam from the very beginning wanted to grow, and he,
he had access to the capital, um, necessary to do it. You know,
this as much as he would later often talk about the company as a sort of a
tech company, or at least a tech adjacent company,
this was a real estate business. And to expand a real estate business,
you need capital, um, you need investment just for the basic,
um, construction and operation of, of your, your spaces. So,
um, Adam was in kind of a elite circles,
or at least on the fringes of that in New York is his wife. Um, uh,
Rebecca Paltrow was, was Gwyneth Paltrow's cousin. Um,
so from the very early days, he, he, he had access to certain circles in,
in New York that, that had money. He was able to sort of tap that to,
to grow the company early on. And then from then on, he was,
he was very good at, at pitching to investors and, and, you know,
some people like to just sort of suggest that there's some sort of con artist
aspect to that, but the reality is it's, it's a,
it's a skill for any business person. And Adam was,
it was especially sort of adept at going to investors and convincing
them that this was not just kind of a boring real estate business. Uh,
but that this was a business that was going to disrupt, um,
the real estate world. And, you know, investors were,
were obviously interested in that,
given how big of a market potentially the commercial office space world was,
they were willing to give him a really kind of shocking amounts of money, uh,
escalating more and more over the years. And,
and that was the crucial difference, um,
between we work and other companies in this industry was Adam's ability to
raise that money, to then spend to, um,
expand that we work empire.
So I wanted to, um, delve into this a bit.
And so let's start with we work's mission. Um, so you, right. Um,
their mission was to elevate the world's consciousness, um,
community, um,
was mentioned in their IPO filing document 150 times, you right,
while office space appeared nine times.
So you called out in the room and I'm saying that we work, uh,
wasn't a real estate company.
It was a tech enabled physical social network.
So this is a big part of the pitch, the rise, wasn't it?
Yeah, this was, this was the pitch that, that somehow, you know,
Adam was attaching, we work to sort of the, the other unicorns,
the other billion dollar companies, uh, in, in Silicon Valley.
And trying to sort of say that we work was, was, yeah,
it was not just renting out space that they were creating this,
this social network and, you know, the, the elevating,
the world's consciousness, um, uh, came,
came sort of later and was sort of the grandest manifestation of,
of Adam's vision, which, which again was, was to kind of,
as he said, many times to, to change the world.
And that was to change the world of real estate, but it was also to,
to do much more of that. And I think those,
the way that he talked about the company, while,
while it could sound ridiculous, and I think towards the end, it, it,
it really came back to bite the company. It was kind of these,
these grand notions that Adam was good at talking about that that led
people to buy into what he was selling.
So I think just, just to go into a bit, you know,
shared office space, um, you know,
what was the kind of offering, um, that, um,
that sort of was behind, um, this ambition or this pitch of, um,
the way company?
The business is pretty simple. Um, we work Brent's out of space in an office.
Um, they go in, they renovate it. Um, they make it look cool with, um, you know,
uh, these, these sort of glass cubes, um,
these big open common spaces with free coffee and beer kegs and,
and all of that. Um, and then they rent out the individual offices. And, and if,
if you're able to do that,
if you're able to fill all those offices and you charge more than you're paying
in rent, then you can make it a decent amount of money. And,
and that's not a new business. There, there have been several over the years,
including, um,
sort of most famously a company formerly known as Regis now called IWG that,
that has been doing this for decades. Um, you know,
they did a boring version of it. Uh, it was kind of, you know,
white walls and acoustic ceiling tiles and that sort of thing. Um,
we work w offered, uh,
a different kind of vision for that, or more modern vision of,
of what the office would be a more millennial friendly kind of vision of,
of what the office would be. And so at its core,
that was something that people wanted. They wanted community in their offices,
they liked the design and they liked the flexibility. You know, we work, if you,
if you wanted, you could rent your office months a month,
which was pretty unusual in the real estate world, um, where you,
you often are stuck with a five or 10 year 20 year lease.
So it was kind of those things that at its core, we work offered.
And for a long time, it was, it was what a lot of people want it.
And then he had other businesses, um,
that he was also developing as well as part of this offering.
Yeah. So, and, and kind of from the beginning, um, the, he had,
he had been thinking about this and, and wanting to, uh,
expand into other businesses.
One of the first that they tried was we live and we live
was, uh, an apartment building. They,
they eventually built to one in Washington, DC, and one in New York city,
uh, that was sort of premised on the same idea.
We're going to give you a small living space. Um,
these were tiny apartments even by New York city standards. Um,
and then these big open common spaces, big kitchens,
a laundry room with a pool table, those kinds of things on the idea that,
that what people wanted was community in their spaces that they wanted to know
their neighbors and interact with them. And, you know, uh, that's, that's,
uh, it goes against a lot of, um, uh, received wisdom in,
in the residential real estate world. Uh,
people don't often voluntarily give up more personal private
space, um, in, in their, in their homes. But, um, that was,
that was the idea. And then from there, they kind of spooled it into, uh,
starting a gym called rise by we, um, in, in New York city.
And, uh, as well as an elementary school was kind of the last
iteration of this, um, called we grow that was led by, uh,
Rebecca Newman, um, uh, Adam's wife and, and,
and was meant to be kind of fill in this sort of holistic world where someone
could, could live at a, at a,
we live go to work at a WeWork and send their kids to a two a week route.
Um, speaking of his wife, Rebecca,
and you write that when Adam Newman was pitching this, we live concept smaller,
personal space, more community space. Um, what was her reply?
Uh, she was not interested in, in, uh, in, in living in that,
uh, in that environment.
So even though they thought this would be a place where,
where the wealthy people would want to live as much as college students looking
for a dorm, um, Rebecca rejected that.
And what was Adam's response when you asked him about this mission, this,
you know, this very, uh,
to elevate the world's consciousness in all of these ambitions,
but did he say to you.
Well, it was a confusing conversation. Um, you know,
I had the thing that I relayed to him was that, uh, when I, um,
mentioned the mission to people, as I was telling them about,
we were people who didn't know that much about the company and told them,
and they may have known that it was,
it was kind of an office space company and a cool office space company at that.
And when I told them the mission was to elevate the world's consciousness,
that most common response I got was what does that mean?
And so when I relayed that to Adam, he sort of got excited and said, that's,
that's perfect. That's exactly what we want.
We're starting the conversation about what it means to elevate the world's
consciousness. And, uh,
I think that it's indicative of the fact that early on when the company was
providing these great office spaces that people liked and,
and was talking about, you know, build a life, not a living,
making a better day at work for people, but that was something that,
that everyone could connect to whether you are an employee or someone renting a
space. And once it got to this notion of elevating the world's consciousness,
which again sounds good and well,
and like something that any of us would want to aspire to, um,
it just felt really disconnected from the reality of what the company, uh,
actually did.
And you mentioned, um, money as a big driver in WeWork's rise.
So private funders valued,
we work as a billion dollar company, um, a unicorn, I learned a new term.
And from your book, uh, DECA corn, if you're working on the billion, uh,
DECA coin. So you quote a member of WeWork's finance team who said, uh,
the nature of private markets is that if nine smart investors
pass, it only takes one relatively dumber investor,
and then suddenly we're valued at $16 billion.
So just say a bit more about, um, the role of private investors, um,
specifically, um, I think SoftBank, um, was one that played a pretty big role.
Yeah, I mean, we worked rise was, was fueled by, by private investors from,
from all kinds of place. Their first investor was benchmark capital, a pretty,
um, one of the sort of blue chip. So account Valley tech firms, they got money,
uh, from a lot of New York institutions, JP Morgan, Goldman Sachs,
and eventually SoftBank and SoftBank was the biggest one. Um, in,
in 2017 they invested $4 billion into WeWork. Uh,
and this was from the vision fund,
which was a sort of a hundred billion dollar venture capital fund F uh,
funded largely by the Saudi Arabian government that,
that SoftBank was going out and investing in companies that were by and large
tech companies. It was, it was meant to focus on,
on artificial intelligence is kind of what,
what Masia saw the founder of SoftBank. And one of the,
sort of the most famous people in,
in kind of the business tech world is what he saw as the future. Um,
he invested in, in we work, um, you know, uh,
extensively on, on this notion of,
of WeWork was going to figure out how to use technology to sort of disrupt the
real estate world. But, but in large part,
he like many others bought into Adam's vision, um, of,
of changing the world and,
and creating this sort of globe spanning real estate company that will be unlike
any other, uh, that existed. And so, you know, the,
these venture capital firms are their whole business model is kind of predicated
on, on hitting home, runs on, um, funding.
These companies that can become these sort of giant world spanning corporations.
And if that means that, uh, you know,
they find 10 companies and 800 or nine of them fall apart,
but one of them becomes the next Amazon or Facebook or Google or Airbnb or Uber,
um, then it's all worth it. So in a lot of ways we work, you know, rise was,
was fueled by this group of people that were,
we're hoping even if the numbers didn't totally make sense that Adam could
figure out how to turn WeWork into one of those kinds of companies.
And SoftBank, um, bet on, uh, we were,
can called it, um, the next Alibaba that you write about. So, um,
Masayoshi son, um, the head of, um,
the vision fund of SoftBank was known for investing $20 million in China's
Ali-Baba this e-commerce platform,
which is very similar to Amazon and ended up with a stake worth more than
a hundred billion dollars, 20 million to a hundred billion dollars in a Chinese,
Chinese tech company. Um, yeah, I mean, he thought big didn't he,
and this comes through in the book when you were writing about sort of his
relationship without a Newman.
Yeah. He that's what he did is he, he,
he takes these kinds of risky bets and then pushes companies to become bigger
and bigger. We say in the book, you know, he, he had had this, uh,
nickname from, from executives at Alibaba who called him Mr. 10 times.
And they said, every time we had a goal or an ambition, he would say,
make it 10 times bigger. And that was the same message he delivered to.
We work into Adam. You know, you, you have a thousand salespeople have 10,000,
you have a million, if a hundred thousand members,
why don't you have a million members? Um, all of, all of those kinds of things,
he was there to sort of push the company and, and Adam was,
was willing to sort of be a vessel for that and push the company to try to meet
those goals.
You also write a great deal about the parties, um, and the antics. So,
uh, I read a lot about tequila shots and fire extinguishers.
So just tell us a couple of stories.
Yeah. Well, you know, I'll tell,
I'll tell the one you're sort of alluding to there, which is, um, in,
in 2016, uh, you know, we work with was running out of cash and,
and they were trying to close a w another big investment round. And,
and they'd gone looking for money in China and really had struggled to get
interest in. And the only investor who came through was,
was a fund called HONY capital. And, uh,
the investors from Honi, including the founder of the firm, John Honi were,
were in New York and Adam invited them to, we live, um, the,
the sort of apartment tower in lower Manhattan where,
where a party was happening. And he told them to come by and check it out. Uh,
they did, uh, Adam took them up to the roof, uh, of the building,
which was not a place he was supposed to go, but at that point, he,
he more or less owned the building. So he was gonna do whatever he wanted. Um,
uh, we were complete, brought up a tray of tequila shots, um, which was just,
uh, a common site at, at pretty much every work event. Adam was, uh,
was a big fan of tequila and, and handed them out, um, at,
at all kinds of events. And then at this one in particular,
he also brought a fire extinguisher and F after everyone gave a toast and,
and took their shots, he, he sprayed the investors, um, with,
with the fire extinguisher and, and it's, uh, it's a ridiculous story. And it,
it sort of repeats itself in all kinds of ways. And, and, and I think on,
on the one hand, obviously in hindsight,
you can look at it as kind of this moment of, of excess.
And there were so many in the company, but also on the way up,
it was one of the things that people loved about WeWork.
People loved living there, you know, young or working there,
rather young people, um, you know, loved going to a company that,
that knew how to throw a good party. And,
and we obviously now know that that is, um, is, is problematic, but,
but in this case, um, with, with the Honi investors, you know, as,
as one of the employees who was on the roof told me, you know,
we closed the deal next week. So, you know, clearly, you know,
while this wood is not something most more conservative business people would
do, it was part of the way Adam operated and part of the swagger that,
that he had, and that attracted people to him.
And part of that was the annual summer camp.
Wasn't a worldly employees and go somewhere. So, um,
I found it really entertaining to read about the summer camps, um,
and the, uh, the requirements for Adam Newman, uh,
for his, um, tent. Uh, just tell us a bit about that.
Yeah, well, we work had this annual summer camp for the first five or six years.
It was held at a, at an actual summer camp, um, outside of, of New York city.
Um, and it was essentially ostensibly, it was a weekend corporate retreat.
What it, what it ended up feeling was, was a big party. Um,
they would invite big musical guests and there was an open bar. And I know,
again, a lot of people who attended describe it as,
as one of the most fun events they've had by the end of it by 2018,
the event was costing the company tens of millions of dollars. And, and, uh,
one employee sort of shared with me this, um,
three and a half page long list of, of materials that,
that the Newman's wanted for,
for their sort of compound at summer camp. Uh, you know, it was a long list of,
of alcohol of snacks.
My favorite was that they needed to have at least 400 plastic shot glasses,
uh, was, was my favorite item on the list. And,
and I think eventually this became sort of galling to a lot of WeWork employees
who were in tiny tents, they were sharing in the cold, um,
and, and in the rain and, and Adam is kind of living in this kind of manner.
So a lot of the talk about changing the world and making it a better place and
elevating the world's consciousness sort of started to fall hollow or feel
hollow when, when he's also doing things like this.
Hmm. So let's discuss, um, the fall of we work. Um, so, uh,
revenues are doubling every year, but expenses were growing, um,
even faster. Um, and so that was, um,
one of the factors. And in fact, I might tie that into blitz scaling,
um, a term that you, um, you write about, um,
that Jenny Silicon Valley and lightening growth and not being too worried about
risk or cost, um, so that you can gain market share.
Um, and this was one of the kind of, um, approaches, um, wasn't it,
that kind of fueled the rise of rework.
Yeah, it was this, this sort of growth at all costs mentality. And,
um, that the idea was that that in order to capture a market, um,
you needed to go Crick quickly before, um,
any of your other competitors could sort of catch up and that if you become this
giant company, you sort of become too big to fail. And,
and this was a thing that, uh,
an idea that was taking over a lot of tech companies and where, where, you know,
becoming a platform was the hot thing to do and becoming a company that sort of
took over any one of these industries. And so, uh, you know, Adam, uh, and,
and we work adopted that, um, mentality at least, and, and sort of,
uh, deployed it, um, deployed it in, in growing we work.
Of course the problem was, it's just, it's just much more expensive to do,
to build these, to build out an actual space than to build a piece of software.
And, and so the blitz scaling, we work was much more expensive than,
than blitz scaling as sort of more traditional tech software company.
So you arrived by 2017. So sort of, um, the last few years,
um, one of his early investors benchmark, uh, was, um,
increasingly worried. Um, they had thought that we work is supposed to be, um,
a $500 billion in profit, but instead it was losing a billion in 2017,
by 2018, we work was losing $2 billion and raise
$702 million in debt financing.
And this is after obviously having raised, um,
large amount of money from private investors. Um,
the financial times that you write about describe their community adjusted
AP da as perhaps the most infamous financial metric of a generation.
So tell us about this, um,
modified measure of what we would normally take as an indicator of
profitability.
Yeah. Um, you know, EBITDA is sort of a traditional way of companies sort of,
you know,
thinking about an and expressing whether they're making money and it's,
and, uh, we were kids sort of added on this phrase community adjusted, uh,
to sort of,
as a way of kind of taking out certain costs that the company said would go away
over time, marketing costs, uh, construction design costs,
and then also streamlining some of the costs of their leases. And,
you know, there's a way in which that,
that idea isn't totally ridiculous. I, I think some,
some people certainly objected to the notion that those costs would just
disappear. Um, what was almost as equally galling was,
was just the name of it. Community adjusted. Nobody knew what that meant.
And it, it felt just like kind of another example of the company, um,
taking this kind of high minded language and almost
trying to pull the wool over people's eyes and not let them see what it was they
were doing, which was just cutting out some of their costs.
And instead kind of inflecting it with this sort of community focused language.
So that was one of the reasons that sort of particularly turned off a lot of
investors.
Um, and yet at that point, SoftBank was considering putting in more. Um,
and I think around that period, um,
there were thinking about as much as $20 billion, which would have put,
we worked valued over a $40 billion.
And when you were writing about a,
you said that would actually double the value that SoftBank had put on the
company just a year ago. And Adam Newman went retained control.
He would work be worth $13 billion making him one of the richest people
in the world,
but the Saudis and Abu Dhabi who were partly being investors in,
um, SoftBank balked at it, uh,
SoftBank's on listing of a snowball phone arm tank. So the deal was off.
So we work needed more money,
and that's why they planned to IPO in 2019.
So just describe, um, this, uh, IPO and the race to do it,
um, before the end of last year, uh, where we work, um,
would have run out of money. Yeah.
Yeah. A lot of people, I think on the outside of these companies look at IPOs,
as you know, this is, this is my chance to get in on the next hot company.
That's gonna fund my kids' college retirement, but in reality,
IPO's are just companies need more money and they have to go to the private
public markets rather to look for it. And then that was the case with WeWork,
where they weren't going to get any more money from SoftBank.
They were continuing to at this incredible rate. Um, and, and to do that,
they, they needed more money. And so that drove the impulse, um,
for WeWork to go public,
Adam Newman had had hopes to avoid it for a long time.
Being a public company just requires more scrutiny. Um, and,
and honestly kind of some, some sort of, uh, suppressing of,
of some of the grand ambitions that he had. Um, so it was not something that,
that he or the company sort of did willfully,
but it was sort of a necessity by the end, if,
if the company was going to be able to continue growing the way that it,
it hoped to.
So as part of promoting this IPO, trying to get interest in it you're right.
That Adam Newman struggled to explain why we work with different from another
real estate leasing company IWG,
which is trading at a market capitalization of $4 billion and
not the $47 billion valuation of WIWORK.
So I'm just telling us about the failure of the IPO.
Yeah. I mean, a few things happened, um, you know, on the one hand,
people finally got to look at the numbers and they saw how much money we work
with losing. Um, they saw that, you know,
there was this feeling or this fear almost in the real estate world that we,
our kids sort of figured something out that the rest of the real estate world
hadn't, but, but when people looked at the numbers, it,
it looked kind of like a normal sort of real estate business. And,
and then when you took sort of the way that looked with kind of all of
this, um,
sort of gobbledygook language that was attached to the company about elevating
the world's consciousness, um, the, the,
the IPO paperwork was filled with these kind of buzzwords and taglines about the
energy of we. Um, and,
and then along with kind of some of the conflicts of interests that emerged that
the way that,
that Adam and his family were sort of profiting off of the company,
gave this perception of, of, of just, uh, you know,
sort of a perfect storm of problems that the numbers weren't good. Um,
no one could quite figure out what the company was or what it intended to
be. And then it seemed to have all these problems sort of at the heart of it.
And a lot of them stemming from Adam, I think just gave, uh,
investors pause and, and in the public markets, these are just more cautious,
more conservative investors than they are, um, in, in the venture capital world.
And, and they weren't willing to take a risk on the country.
Okay. So just say a bit more about, um,
the kind of conflicts of interest that, um, that you write about,
which is part of the issue with public investors sort of bulking, and then,
then, then basically having to pull the IPO.
Yeah. There were a few things, I mean,
the biggest one was that that Adam himself was, was the, uh, owner of,
of several buildings that we work with leasing. Um, so, so in, in that way,
uh, his own company was paying him rent. Um, and,
and know when it comes time to negotiate the lease, uh,
who who's gonna going to win out on that negotiation. And,
and it was those kinds of things that just gave at least the perception of a
company that, that did not have strong corporate governance. Um,
there was, there was another case in which Adam had sold, um,
had, had personally bought trademarks or these,
we related trademarks that he then sold to the company for
$5.9 billion. Um, and, and in some ways these were sort of accounting decisions,
but, but in, in, in total, they kind of gave the perception of a,
of a company that was as much a family business, um, as it was, uh,
a company ready to be public.
And you also wrote that, um,
Adam Newman sold millions of dollars worth of shares in 2017. Um,
and the question that you asked was, um,
why cash out if there are greater riches ahead? So why did he do it?
Um, good question. Uh, you know, I, I think that,
uh, the obvious answer is that he, he, he wanted to cash out, um, and,
and that he wanted, uh,
at the time to have these hundreds of millions of dollars that he would
otherwise have to be waiting for. I mean, the, the cynical view is,
is did he actually believe that that the company was going to be worth as much
as, as the private investors were valuing? Um, I think he did. Uh,
I think he knew he was, he was pulling some kind of trick, but, uh, but, um,
and that, and that this might not work out,
but I think he also believed very strongly and in the company and,
and the fact that it was, and, and a belief that it was,
it was going to become as big. And he, uh, as he had Masayoshi son,
um, uh, hoped it would be, but, you know,
the Newman's at one point owned seven homes, um,
and were spending close to a hundred million dollars on personal real estate
alone. So, um, you have to fund that in some way. And,
and Adam, you know, it was, is not alone in, in startup founders,
sort of selling off some of their shares in order to,
to live the lifestyle they, they want, but he certainly was,
was more extravagant than most.
And how did that, uh, Newman end up getting ousted from WIWORK. Um,
and, um, and I think you ride that, um, SoftBank's, um,
uh, Masayoshi son said we created a monster. Um,
so they were acquired to the exit for Adam wasn't weren't they?
Yeah. You know,
eventually once things went sour with the IPO, um,
it became clear to we works backers and Adam's backers
that, that a lot of the problems were tied up with him and,
and that it was going to be hard for the company to move forward. And so, um,
you know, S and the company also needed needed money. So,
so SoftBank came in with this, this kind of rescue package, um,
part of which was predicated on Adam, stepping down as, as CEO and,
and, uh, and it was clear that now, you know,
the backer that he had once depended on, um,
was now saying that he was not the person most well-equipped to,
to lead the company forward. And, and, you know, he was,
he was kind of out of chips at that point. All of his money was at this point,
you know, still tied up in the company. He,
the last thing he wanted was to see it go down. And,
and certainly in that moment, um, it felt like there was no other option,
but for, for Adam to, to step down.
So SoftBank has not been sued haven't they?
So there's a legal dispute going on right now. So what's happened to we work.
Um, yes, the, the exit package that,
that SoftBank and Adam agreed to this roughly billion dollar exit packages is
now under dispute there's there's, uh, the lawyers are involved. Um,
uh, the SoftBank is claiming that, that we work itself, uh,
sort of did not live up to various terms of the deal. And that is,
is going to be adjudicated in, in, in the months ahead. And, and we'll,
we'll see what happens. Um, we work itself is,
is trying to figure out how to be a commercial real estate company in,
in the pandemic, um, which is, is a tricky proposition. You know, they,
they have, uh, given up the dream of,
of we grow and we live and,
and all these other things and are trying to focus on being a real estate
company. Um, and getting back to the core of kind of what the company does.
Um, the trouble of course,
is that the brand is a bit tarnished and they're going to have to fix that.
And then, and then the other trouble is that right now, um, there,
there are few things worse than, than being an office space operator. And,
and they're trying to figure out along with the rest of the commercial real
estate world, um, how to get people to come back to offices and,
and what that will look like.
So what's next for Adam Newman? Have you followed that?
Um, a few weeks ago, he, he invested in a, in a new company. Um, it's a,
it's sort of a residential, uh, focused, uh, startup. Um, he's,
he's made several investments, um, over the course of this year. Uh,
I don't suspect that he's going to go quietly into early retirement in his,
in his early forties. He's, he's the kind of person who, um, you know,
worked very hard for, for everything else that's been said about him. And,
and I think wants to make an impact,
and it will just sort of remain to be seen what he decides to do. Um,
but I think he's,
he's the kind of person who people are going to be willing to take a chance on
whether it's investors, whether it's politics is something he talked about, but,
um, I feel fairly confident that we will, we will hear from Adam Newman again.
And finally,
what is your biggest takeaway from the WIWORK story?
I think as we looked at this story,
I saw it as a story about the last decade in a number of ways
and the decade of the 2010s in, in kind of the startup world and,
and the fact that so much of the growth that existed in, in a decade of growth,
um, was these kinds of companies that grew, grew very quickly.
And some of them have obviously become very successful in crucial parts of our
lives. And,
and others have spent lots of money and been unable to figure out how to
actually make things work while kind of warping these economies along the way.
So I think as, as we sort of enter a new era, I'm,
I'm eager to find out what lessons, if any,
the sort of venture capital startup world learns from this.
And I think one is just that, you know,
growth at all costs has it's has this dangerous and,
and growing in so many different directions at,
at such speed can push a company to do things it isn't good at can push a
company to do things that's not, it's not equipped or prepared to take on. And,
and it's, it's gonna be hard to tell future founders to, to be more humble,
um, in, in their ambitions. But, but I think having some amount of humility, um,
even while trying to build a giant fast-growing company is,
is going to be a necessary ingredient to, to long-term success.
Thank you very much. Um, it's a great note to end on,
so thank you very much to read why Dimon and do pick up his new book,
billion dollar loser.
It is a stimulating tale with lots of anecdotes,
and who knew that coworking office space could be such a wild read.
Thank you all for tuning in for listening for more podcasts,
please go to intelligence squared.com and I'm going to you.